Một người mục tiên tháng bệnh bộ nông nghiệp và mối trường bán hành văn bản số 4.2.8 người y bán nhân dân các tình.
Thành phố khu vực bóc bộ về việc chủ đạo uống phó với mưa lớn,
vui cơ lũ, ngập lũ, lũ quét, sật lợ đất.
Thật gió chật chế bản tin dự báo, tình báo về mưa lớn, vui cơ lũ, ngập lũ, lũ, lũ,
sật lợ đất và thông tin kì thời đại đủ cho các cấp chính quyền cơ sở và người dân để chủ độ phòng chán.
Chỉnh hai lực lượng xuống kích kiểm tra, ra sất các hú dân cửa văn xong,
xuống cuộc thấp chú, có nghĩ cơ sây ra ngập lũ, lũ quét,
sật lợ đất để chủ độ khơi thông dòng chảy những nơi bị tác,
nhỉ? Tổ chức gì rồi? Sất á người dân để người ăn quà.
Các tình, thành phố tổ chức lượng cành gác kiểm soát, hỗ trợ,
lướng dẫn bảo đảm ra thông ăn tỏng trong người và phương vịt.
Nhất là tại các ngầm chàn, cuộc ngập xong, nước chảy sết,
cuộc đả sây ra sật lợ, họ có nghĩ cơ sây ra sật lợ.
Kinh quyết không trong người và phương vịt đi qua nếu không bảo đảm ăn quan,
bố chi nước lượng, bởth tương, phương vịt đi khóc cuộc sự của
đảm bảo gió thông thuốc chến các trục xa thông chính khi sẻ ra ngồi lớn.
Cơ địa phương chình hai các biệt pháp đảm bảo ăn quan đe điều,
hù chữa và hà dù, bố chi nước lượng thương trực đợi vẫn hành điều biết và sáng sàng
sự lý các tình muốn có thể sẻ ra.
Sáng sàng phương ăn, têu nước trong uống bảo vệ sàng sốt,
cuộc công nghiệp, cuối đau thiệt, cuộc tập trung dân cơ, sáng sàng lực lượng,
phương tiện để kiểu hộ, cứu nạn khi có uống cầu.
Tăng thường thông tiên về giữ biến phủ hộ lớn đến các cấp chính quyền
người dân để trụ động phòng chán, tổ chức diệt bán nghiêm tốt,
thường sinh bảo kháu vệ bộ nông nghiệp và mối triệu,
qua cuộc khoản đi đe điều và phòng trong thinh tàn.